♪ [народна грузинська музика]
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
Усе, йдемо. Наступний танок, що у нас?
[Київ,
Наддніпрянщина]
[грузинською]
Елене, ти вже прийшла?
Ходіть, ходіть сюди!
[грузинською]
Як ти?
Діана!
[грузинською]
Як ви?
Як ви, дівчата?
[грузинською]
Як ви відпочиваєте в цю спеку?
Я переїхала до України у 2000 році разом з родиною.
Особливо складно було сину,
[Манана Сулаквелідзе
президентка грузинського центру «Іберія»]
йому було тоді шість років.
Він не знав мови і через мовний бар'єр
він дуже страждав.
Взагалі не хотів вивчати нові мови.
Я почала шукати у Києві грузинську школу
і танцювальну грузинську студію.
На жаль таких закладів я не знайшла, бо їх просто не було.
Тому я вирішила,
що маю тут відкрити грузинський центр
та грузинську танцювальну школу-студію.
Це б вирішило проблему навчання мого сина
і усіх грузинських дітей, що живуть в Україні.
♪ [народна грузинська музика]
[грузинською]
Добре! Живіт!
Сідаємо!
[грузинською]
Живіт
На сьогодні існує недільна школа,
де вчаться наші дітки, які живуть в Україні
Тут вони вивчають рідну мову, історію Грузії,
грузинські танці і пісні.
На мою думку діти мають знати
культуру і мову своїх батьків, своїх пращурів.
Ця робота стала ціллю і смислом мого життя.
♪ [народна грузинська музика]
Я пишаюсь тим, що я —
[Нато Кварацхелія
юристка] український,
українська юристка,
але за походженням — грузинка.
Я досконало знаю рідну мову —
закінчила грузинську школу,
закінчила українську вищу (освіту).
І тому до мене по звертаються багато грузинів.
Я, живучи в Україні,
маю змогу допомагати
своїм співвітчизникам.
В Україні, в чужій країні,
де вони опинилися не завжди за своєю волею.
А за якихось обставин,
іноді за тяжких.
Тому для мене
це робота для душі —
допомога моїм співвітчизникам.
[грузинською]
Робіть щось з лицем
Ось там дівчина, що стоїть
♪ [народна грузинська музика]
[грузинською]
Це Тордія, ось там ще інші дівчата
Марі, ти вже прийшла?
[грузинською]
Добрий день
Ми і так малочисельний народ, розумієте?
І якщо будемо ось так губитися, то виходить,
[Марина Донадзе
журналістка, викладачка грузинської мови]
що буде складно.
Ось тут є напис:
«Мова —
це обдарування народу».
Дійсно, якщо мова втрачена —
втрачена і людина.
Наша мова — дуже давня
Насправді, релігія і мова
зберегли грузинський народ.
Від батьків багато залежить і вони дуже стараються.
Є тут у мене такі батьки,
котрі самі виросли в Україні.
Наприклад біженці з Абхазії,
Ми теж, як і ви (українці) пережили багато страждань,
Вони тут виросли, але зберегли все одно мову.
Вони навчалися тут, отримали вищу освіту.
Їм теж важко, але цей центр їм допомагає.
♪ [народна грузинська музика]
Додому, де я народилася, я взагалі не можу поїхати. Бо це Абхазія.
Розумієте?
І коли я тут, в Україні, розповідала,
що ми, грубо кажучи, тікали з рідного дому,
ми тікали, а нас наздоганяла куля.
І це було!
Коли я перетинала кордон на автомобілі,
то я поверталася, не зважаючи на те, що куля вже була близько.
Я забирала інших людей, дітей,
собак, котів...всіх.
І так робила декілька маршрутів.
Коли я тут розповідала про Абхазію,
про те, як ми все втратили.
Мати щодня говорила:
«Завтра буде перехід, завтра буде перехід.»
Але цього переходу не сталося, і моєї мами теж не стало.
Коли я  це розповідала,
то мене люди не дуже розуміли.
А зараз, коли це сталося з Кримом,
то ті, які мене тоді слухали, то кажуть:
«Ой, як зараз ми тебе розуміємо, як це тяжко.»
Ціль велика —
не втратити свою мову, культуру, історію,
і передавати це майбутнім поколінням
Ми вже, можна так сказати, виростили
одне покоління дітей,
які тут народилися і виросли
та закінчили школу,
отримали вищу освіту.
Дехто, з них, повернувся до Грузії,
а решта залишилися в Україні.
Це наші випускники.
Вони були на концерті у нас
Вони приїжджають навіть з Грузії,
щоб побувати у нас на концерті,
бо для них — це ностальгія.
...Ця дружба триває і досі,
яскравим прикладом  цього сьогодні є грузини,
що проживають в Україні,
та українці, що проживають у Грузії.
У наших народів є одна головна спільна риса —
жага до свободи та незалежності.
[оплески]
Ще раз вітаємо всіх з Днем незалежності Грузії!
♪ [народна грузинська музика]
[Грузинська спільнота на території України почала формуватися у XVIII ст.]
[через погіршення соціально-економічної ситуації в Грузії,]
[а також через напади Османської та Іранської імперій.]
[Значно збільшилася спільнота наприкінці ХХ ст., коли Росія окупувала грузинський регіон — Абхазію.]
[Сьогодні в Україні мешкає майже 35 тис. грузинів.]
[Не забуваючи рідну мову та культуру вони зберігають тут власну ідентичність.]
[Автор проекту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Оператори
Марія Теребус та Микола Носок]
[Субтитри
Владислав Цовма]
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Серія відео створена за підтримки USAID]